[Music]
DevOps is short for development
operations it focuses on a collaboration
between developers and other roles
developers typically work in isolation
they can't do this anymore
we need to work in conjunction with the
operations people and the QA people we
need to find out how to develop an
application from start to end from me
inception all the way through to
production and production support it's
about thinking about how things are
going to work in the future when we're
in the very beginning stages of the
operations and they also of the great
importance is on automating the process
we don't want to do things man do
anymore we want everything to be fast
totally automated and reliable now I
will take over from Phil and we'll move
to our next topic now let's understand
agile and see how agile led to the
development of DevOps in the late 1990s
several methodologies began to gain
increasing public attention each having
a different combination of all the new
ideas these methodologies emphasized
close collaboration between the
development team and business
stakeholders frequent delivery of
business value tight self-organizing
teams and smaller ways to craft confirm
and deliver code agile software
development is an umbrella term for a
set of methods and practices based on
the values and principles expressed that
eyel manifesto solutions evolved through
collaboration between self-organizing
cross-functional teams utilizing the
appropriate practices for their context
here you have a diagram of scrum
software development framework for agile
where the product owner starts with
product backlog the development team and
the product owner scope the Sprint
backlog from it during a sprint planning
meeting the development team works on
the Sprint backlog items and the longest
duration as per agile that you can have
for a sprint cycle is four weeks and at
the end of these four weeks you need to
be able to deliver a potentially
shippable increment what is the meaning
of potentially shippable increment well
in easiest terms the deliverable should
be complete and should have the quality
that if needed you should be able to
deploy it in a production environment
well that is a lot of work you need to
complete the coding completely retesting
complete integration testing do
integration testing creator software
build deploy the bill do smoked for
sanity testing and create a package for
final deployment eventually deploy it or
a test or staging environment also maybe
run a couple of performance tests
creates and configure a deployment
environment and complete the entire
software setup that you will need on
that only after completing these tasks
if all goes well you will have a
potentially shippable increment that can
then be deployed in production and it
will not break anything and it will work
itself and function as it's supposed to
be how do you achieve all of this at
four weeks where do all the tasks leave
you with the time to write the code this
is where DevOps comes into play that
extends what a child says to have
business and development work together
with the DevOps development and
operations work closely and collaborate
more some of the principles of agile
manifesto that led to a DevOps
environment are the highest priority
being to satisfy the customer through
early and continuous delivery of
valuable software also delivering
working software frequently from a
couple of weeks to a couple of months
with preference to the shorter times
the businesspeople and developers must
work together daily throughout the
project
DevOps extends this to their development
and operations works together daily
throughout the project their work not
only talks about collaboration between
development and operations but improve
the collaboration between all themes of
your project including the business
DevOps also promotes a lot of automation
to complete to so many tasks and steps
that go into making a deliverable
potentially shippable tools to replace
non human steps like wealth creation
environment set up trigger test cases
automated deployments multiple times a
day here you see a software development
cycle from code chicken all the way to
deployments in production you can see
how with DevOps automation and tooling
you can include so many different tools
for different steps of an sdlc cycle
these tools that you automate the
previously done manual steps with
automated tools you can do multiple
bills in a day run test cases as many
number of times after build gets created
and integrate continuous quality control
into your delivery cycle without much
manual intervention you can also include
environment setup and configuration and
final deployment with the use of these
automated tools and software
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here